un carré de 43 cm sur un mur de 9 mètres
de long pour 2 m 62 oh un seul objectif
y faire passer un ballon de football en
un minimum de tentatives un défi lancé à
evry dans l'essonne durant le
confinement et qui aujourd'hui fait le
tour de la france
[Musique]
nous sommes en 2010 neuf premières
vidéos de la lucarne d'evry qui réalise
un véritable buzz sur internet les
habitants du quartier tente chaque jour
de réussir l'exploit
puis c'est au tour de personnalités de
s'illustrer comme l'ancien attaquant du
psg nenê
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que le lieu de galles populaires comme
ça c'est beau c'est un gros plus pour
nous et pour la ville tu d'autant plus
qu'on vient d'ouvrir un quartier
difficile en tir ami et du matin voilà
on est assez mal réputé tue pas des
petits verres ou des faits de violence
et de faire parler d'un bilan bien
sérieusement ça c'est que du bonus coutu
plus et maintenant evry s'exporte dans
plus de 30 villes de villiers le bel en
passant par poissy avec une
reconstitution grandeur nature du mur et
l'organisation d'un championnat et on en
profite aussi pour mettre des ateliers
en poids des ateliers santé ce faire en
sorte que le plaisir que lui puisse être
conjuguées avec de l'utilité derrière le
comédien et humoriste alban ivanov
originaire des yvelines étaient aussi
présents pour assurer le spectacle est
la lucarne passera prochainement par
marseille avec une finale nationale pour
les meilleurs joueurs qui se déroulera
en juillet à evry